c'est toujours pour épater des femmes
que j'ai agi sinon je serais resté
immobile vous avez éprouvé le besoin
d'écrire de vous raconter d'écrire sur
votre enfance vos amours votre milieu et
parler parfois de vos proches alors
phénomène de mode envie d'être compris
règlement de compte besoin
d'argent allez répondez franchement gu
marchand présent à quoi ah moi l'avance
que m'a donné Michel l' fond était
vraiment
conséquent moi je suis aux éditions
Carpentier alors c'était pas le cas non
non c'était et puis c'est un petit peu
pour épacter ma ma compagne voilà
pourquoi pourquoi vous lui demandez de
se faire Adelina pourquoi vous lui
demander de se fa la
connerie une connerie je sais pas elle
vous surveille votre épouse vous
surveille mais elle me donne des coups
de pied
elle est 10 fois plus c'est pour les p
j'ai voulu les pâter parce que bon elle
est professeur de français professeur
d'anglais déclaration d'amourec il
narrête pas je voulais lespâter c'est
tout vous savez un vieux avec une jeune
femme comm elle elle a 31 ans au
départis moi oh là là j'ai dépassé 60000
km depuis à peu près pas loin de
10000 c'est 40 ans d'écart
environ je voulais l'adopter pas voulu
Adelina surprenant ravi être
médiatisé c'est pour les fans de moi
aussi c'est pour les fanss de moi oui
c'est vrai pour les fins de mois on
habite à la
campagne et c'est clair on a h d' c'est
clair être beau faire le beau devant
votre belle votre jeune épouse et en
même temps avoir un peu plus d'argent
gagner de l'argent donc Guy Marchand n'a
pas l'habitude d'entendre parler de vous
en dehors de votre métier de chanteur j'
de comédien sauf donc l'année dernière
vous avez pris une belle place quand
même dans les pages people avec votre
mariage avec
Adelina quand même ou ouais mais il y a
plein de choses derrière ça parce que
c'était amusant c'est puis que je suis
fier tout le monde se demande comment je
j'ai pu draguer une beauté comme ça bon
alors en plus parce que bon elle
elleelle en bah voilà ça y est je me
réponds non mais
oublou
là c'est la vanité c'est pas
l'exibitionn c'est la vanité c'est la
vanité c'est non c'était amusant parce
que ça ça c'est un turbo au bonheur un
peu d'en parler en plus tout ça finira
mal entre nous parce que le présent
enfin on a une telle différence d'âge
que c'est le présent que l'éternité
entre nous il y a pas de problème mais
c'est vrai qu'on a laisser parler plus
que d'habitude à un autre niveau c'était
amus an et puis elle a été complice de
ça on a trouvé ça oui pardon ah oui B
c'est parce que lui parce que j' je le
surveille
par est là votre caméra est
là oubliez l'objectif
d' Jean-Claude d'Ille n' pas ch voilà
vous remarquerez juste une chose m c'est
que directement les people c'est le
réflexeadresse au photograp au Paparadis
donc il mais arrêtez vous allez finir
par le
mettre non mais attends le phot le
photoc on é au festival c'est les qui
font
ça encore plus sopistiqué moi avec ta
barbe de 3 jours non attends non merde
il nous les gonfles non calement
franchemental a
Merz allez gu quelle image de bonheur en
tout cas ma colère est
tombée tant mieux quel travail d'être à
la hauteur donc de la demande aussi
d'une jeune femme de de 30 ans comme
vous dites mon seul public il est là
donc quand même la femme est au centre
aussi de votre vie dans votre livre
d'ailleurs le début Chau vous dites à un
moment donné en parlant de votre mère ma
mère était belle à couper le souffle
aussi belle qu'une actrice de cinéma
comme Sophia Lorine elle planait avec
élégance sur la misère de notre rue elle
était jalousée mais c'était la reine du
quartier elle était vraiment c'est la
plus belle femme que j'ai vous avez vu
sa photo c'était vraiment un vagarner ma
mère c'était une femme sublime ce n'est
pas vagarner que l'on voit mais c'est
vous c'est votre livre ou ma maman pas
est pas là mais c'est toujours pour
épater des femmes que j'ai agi sinon je
serais resté immobile immobile cétait
votre moteur quand j'étais petit je
faisais des calipettes pour épater mes
petites copines je marchais sur les
mains je plongeais je chantais pour pour
épater les dames voilà c'est les côes
cassé et il continue à le faire pour
vous Adelina de temps en temps vous lui
dites Guy c'est bon je t'aime tu peux en
faire moins puis le jour pas de temp
comment trois fois par jour tris fois
par jour mon qutien en tout cas vous
avez tout fait et ce sont les femmes qui
vous ont d'ailleurs fait bouger changer
de changer de très peu oui mais votre je
pas mais votre premierre épouse vous a
fait changer de milieu aussi c'est comme
ça que vous êtes devenu ch de l'acordéon
AB Brams et de la box au polo c'était
pas mon milieu mais ça m'avait fait
rêver c'était Julien polo du polo le PO
POLOLO ouis franchement mais ça m'a fait
rêver et dans quel milieu vous vous
sentez le mieux je sens bien nul par moi
c'estd le le l'étranger de de Cam c'est
mon mon livre préféré étranger c'est non
elle me dit tu l'as pas
lu qu'est-ce que tu racontes tu l'as pas
lu j'ai lu j'ai lu le début
bon femmes important de ma vie il y en a
pas beaucoup hein c'est il y a eu deux
femmes importantes la mère de mes
enfants puis voilà c'est tout et
elle don elle et les femmes MT toujours
abandonné pas abandonné non mais pas toi
tu m'as pas abandonné mais mais j'ai
toujours été quitté quitté j'ai toujours
été abandonné si ça peut les a faire
marrer en attendant leur
tour j'ai toujours été abandonné largué
parce que effectivement ce qui me
plaisait chez les femmes c'est leur côté
maternel et alors les femmes qui
voulaient des vrais hommes elles en
avaient marre à la fin parce que
franchement c'est toujours côté maternel
chez les femmes qui m'a attiré la bonne
femme qui veut un
St St pas je perds mon ventre pour les
femmes mais c'est pas pour avoir des
muscles c'est pour pas avoir de com tu
fais pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Ina mire Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche